les sceptiques de l'euro avaient
peut-être raison les prix de certains
produits flancent déjà avant même le
fameux passage à la monnaie unique c'est
ce que révèle en tout cas une enquête du
magazine 60 millions de consommateurs
des hausses qui peuvent même atteindre
40%, mais les industriels et la grande
distribution réfutent ces chiffres
explications et reportage Sophie Roland
Georges minangoi cette consommatrice ses
habitudes mais ce geste lui coûte 21% de
plus qu'il y a un an et ce n'est pas
tout plus 18,5% pour cette marque de
lait plus 6% pour cette eau minérales
c'est le résultat d'une enquête menée
par un mensuel de consommateur entre
juin 2000 et juin 2001 alors à qui la
faute la grande distribution et les
industriels se renvoient la balle pour
ce journaliste qui a supervisé l'étude
cette flambée des prix et surtout
imputable aux industriels qui anticipent
l'arrivée de l'euro
en prévision de l'arrivée de l'euro
certains industriels ont bien sûr
travaillé sur leur politique tarifaire
de 2002 certains apparemment n'y sont
pas parvenus ne sont pas parvenus à
déterminer le comportement du
consommateur en 2002 et dans ce
brouillard dans lequel ils sont plongés
certains ont décidé de prendre des
hausses de sécurité avant le basculement
mais les fabricants des produits mis en
cause dénoncent la méthode de cette
enquête elle a été menée dans seulement
10 grandes surfaces de la région
parisienne surtout il conteste ses
résultats les hausses de prix existent
mais ne seraient pas aussi importantes
et elle s'explique par l'augmentation du
coût des matières premières et la mise
en place des 35 heures
il y a énormément d'explications qui
suffisent me semble-t-il largement
à expliquer ce qui se passe sans aller
chercher des explications paranoïaque du
côté d'un supposé effet de l'euro du
côté du gouvernement s'est enquête aussi
fait réagir elle contredit les résultats
d'une étude menée par la direction de la
concurrence et des fraudes nous nous
avons fait une étude depuis trois mois
sur 3000 points de vente pour 20000
produits avec 300 agents de la dgcf qui
montre que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de dérapage des prix ce que dit
l'enquête aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a eu
des augmentations pour certaines
importantes pour certains produits que
nous connaissions déjà les résultats de
l'enquête du gouvernement seront publiés
la semaine prochaine elle permettra de
savoir si le passage à l'euro représente
ou non un vrai risque inflationniste une
chose est sûre industrielle les grandes
distributions se sont engagés à
stabiliser les prix entre le 1er
novembre et le 31 mars 2002